hey last time 47 meters down is directed
by johannes roberts the director of the
other side of the door and stars mandy
moore and claire Holt as sisters who are
on a vacation and they think hey it'd be
fun to go in the ocean and take pictures
of sharks while in a protective cage
until the line breaks and they get
trapped at the bottom of the ocean 47
meters down I was actually pretty
excited for this movie I love sharks
first of all I've always been fascinated
by them it was originally going to be
direct-to-video like last year and the
company that distributed it picked it up
and gave it a theatrical release at the
very last minute they changed the title
and everything and so we're getting it
in theaters and maybe you should just
stay direct a video 47 meters down is
the kind of film that's great in concept
but once you actually see it in
execution you're like oh yeah they don't
really have much else to do after they
get under the water do they they just
kind of have to stay in the cage and
there's their sharks you know after Jaws
countless shark movies have tried to
replicate that success even the Jaws
sequels couldn't do it and the problem
that they all have is that they all seem
to think the reason Jaws is so good is
the shark it's not it's the characters I
watch jaws over and over again because I
love chief Brody and Matt Hooper and
Quint now just because the shark pops up
a lot in the last half but every shark
movie after that just thinks well people
just want to see sharks a lot right like
who cares about character because the
characters in this movie are atrocious
the reasoning behind why they even get
into the cage the entire motivation for
the rest of the film is because Mandy
Moore just got dumped and she wants to
make her boyfriend jealous by posting
photos of her doing something really
exciting because he thinks she's boring
Wow I don't give a and the banter
that goes back and forth between these
sisters is so over-the-top and so
idiotic there's
things subtle about any of it it's all
very loud and kind of grating and it
feels like you're watching a straight to
VOD movie which makes sense because
that's what they were originally making
it also seems like the film thinks it's
a lot scarier than it actually is the
director actually put his name right
above the title when it comes up in the
beginning it says johannes roberts 47
meters down like he's John Carpenter or
something the motivation for them
getting into the water was so weak the
first ten minutes was just your
stereotypical setup to try to make the
characters interesting in some way so
the only thing they do is have many more
be going through a breakup and that's it
after that they're in the water the
Sharks really disappoint they look fine
but they don't seem to really have much
to do other than to every once in a
while
create a jump-scare terribly inept
sharks come out of the darkness with a
loud burst of music and why do I say
that because they're really awful at
biting they're constantly missing the
limbs of these girls because of the main
characters the ending of the film also
is definitely going to polarize people
because it's one of those endings where
you're like I didn't care before and now
I really don't care at all 47 meters
down is very disappointing I didn't find
the film scary I found the characters
awful
I found the performances pretty bad too
unfortunately and I have liked Mandy
Moore and other things I'm going to give
47 meters down a D+ guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to the start of my Christopher Nolan
series this weekend with his first film
following I'm excited to bring that to
you guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]